in the video you're about to see a man
named Eugene Nims born in 1866 will tell
you about his experiences during the
late 1800s in the area now known as
Oklahoma State back in those days
Oklahoma looked a lot different for
example here's a map from
1869. it was all American Indian
Territory back then and by 1892 the land
was divided between the Indian lands and
the American settlement territory back
then the government would occasionally
open up territories for settlement
through what were called land rushes or
land runs and there were two major ones
in the Oklahoma territory the land run
of 1889 and 1893 up to 160 acres of land
were given to each qualifying citizen
thanks to the Homestead Act of 1862 the
deal was you had to live on a land for
five years improve move it and cultivate
it and you couldn't leave the land for
more than six months at a time otherwise
you had to give it back to the
government
Eugene Nims was in Oklahoma during the
land run of 1893 and he wrote in on
Horseback like many others did but Mr
Nims wasn't there just to claim his 160
acres of land he was a businessman he
sold Lumber to the people for building
their houses opened up several Banks and
even established telephone service in
the region so here he is Mr Eugene Nims
describing his experiences during that
time in American history
those opening days of Oklahoma
were exciting and very
it is too bad that we did not have the
moving pictures that time
to make a record of that wonderful thing
never had been enacted before never will
be again
we were all pioneers
in the Pioneer Circle
and when we finally organized the
telephone company
we called it the Pioneer Telephone
two days
we did not feel
happy or if they were located whether
they would stay there
[Music]
Oklahoma
territory was different than any other
territory there had ever been open
other
States had been opened by people going
in gradually and settling
the country
in town that afterwards grew in the city
but Oklahoma opens
almost overnight
[Music]
it was necessary as Mr Fair said for us
to have telephone service
the towns where most of them located
inland
do not but if you're on the Railroad and
we had no communication detect my
horseback
and sometimes it took days to
three years like
places that we were doing the most
businesses
if you haven't got together and
organize a company and built a toy line
between two of these points
yeah
at that time
we did not have
very much money
and little experience
in the service that we gave
but sometimes rather crude but on the
whole very good
I realized now more than I did then
that
are
object
and the intention was to give service
more than it was to get a financial
return